Speaker 1: I'm going to play for you some number
of incoherent seconds. I guess it's about 90
seconds of Mypillow founder and CEO Mike Lindell
appearing on Steve Bannon's program. And I have to
tell you, at this point, I genuinely don't know
whether Steve Bannon takes Lindell seriously,
because Bannon is as much of an incoherent joke
as Lindell, or whether Bannon sees Lindell more
of his like as a as a goofy entertainment element.
But he doesn't take him seriously. There was a
segment on Steve Bannon's actually I'm wrong. This
was on Lindell TV. You know what? I don't know
where this seems to have been a simulcast both on
Lindell TV and on Steve Bannon's war room. I don't
know where a pillow is upset with Ron DeSantis.
For some reason, he's calling him a backstabber
and all of these different things. The segment
starts with Mike Pillow literally holding a pillow
and then moving it out of frame. I wasn't able to
find what took place in the 15 seconds before this
clip starts, but the presence of the pillow makes
me think it might be pretty damn interesting.
See if you can make heads or tails out of this.
And then if you're listening, imagine that as this
segment starts. Mike Pillow is moving a physical
pillow out of screen. So what is going on?
Speaker 3: Descent is a pretty straight guy.
Speaker 1: What is he heckling you it because he's
upset about what you're doing in Miami Dade.
Speaker 3: Or what is a shot across
Mike Lindell's ball. What's going.
Speaker 4: On here? Well, let me let
me let me try and frame this and then we'll just
see. We don't know why, but you can draw your own
conclusions. So this morning, what he hosted at
a lawyer are six lawyers are shot in this shop,
in this little round table. Well, one of them
is Libby Locke, who represents Dominion voting
machines against the should run thing against
Mike Lindell, Rudy Giuliani, and many others.
Speaker 1: You guys understanding this so far?
Speaker 4: And he called her in his opening
statement when he introduced her. Libby is an
extraordinary at First Amendment defamation law.
Well, I'm telling you, Ron, you just
watch how you stand what's going on in
our country. There's a reason that the whole
country wanted me to bitch out of the RNC.
Speaker 1: Well, that obviously isn't the case.
Speaker 4: When they did the rest. First
of all, it's because I want to get rid of machines
and and make our election. We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines, elections
and not elections. So what he did, I told them,
I told The Daily Beast today, Steve, they
called me and I said, because they watched
it and they said, let me tell you, they.
Speaker 1: Called me and they said, Sir.
Speaker 4: I said, he just blew any chance if
he was thinking of running for president. Your
ship has sailed. Run. You just throw endorsed
Donald Trump right now and try and save face
because you don't know what the people want.
Speaker 1: Now, I want to remind everybody
that the I believe it was the day after Trump
announced in November that he was running in 2024.
I don't remember what the context was,
but the day after or two days later, Mike
Pillow said DeSantis is about to endorse Trump.
DeSantis isn't going to run in 24. Any day now,
he's going to come out and say, Actually,
I endorse Donald Trump. Now, of course,
that didn't happen. Like almost all of Mike
Pillow's predictions, it has not come true.
But what is our understanding of pillow at this
point? Is he deeply delusional or does he believe
the things he said? I don't know the answer. I've
interviewed pillow twice. I've most recently been
leaning towards. He's serious about this stuff.
He means it. But now I'm sort of going back like,
could anyone really be this delusional? Does Steve
Bannon take him seriously? I also don't know the
answer to that. I don't know what is going
on with this guy. We can only hope and pray
that at least within the Republican Party, which
is the only place he has any credibility left,
he is increasingly seen as a joke and
ostracized and moved to the margins of
the political this discussion. But I knew that
day that he appeared at the White House during
Colbert with Trump to announce that he believes
Trump was God given a God given president.
Gosh darn it, you could tell this guy was trouble.
And he certainly has turned out to be trouble. And
he told me a few months ago that he's like in
for 35 million. At that point, he was in for
35 million so far. And all of this election stuff
and machines and investigations and whatever. It's
got to be more than that by now. At some point,
the money's got to run out, you would think. But
there is the latest from Mike Pillow holding a
pillow for part of a segment with Steve Bannon.